I'm curious earlier you said recipes
Chris Dorner now his his I feel like his
story
and his Manifesto I feel like that's
such an interesting
uh
topic that doesn't get brought up enough
because I do feel like
it's kind of like
depending on your perspective on it I
mean obviously nobody should ever
condone like people dying and stuff but
I but I I always was thinking in my head
I was like man I wonder if anybody will
ever tackle that topic from like a
conceptual way through hip-hop whether
it's a record whether it's telling that
story maybe I'll keep you in the game I
can't throw it for you cab but we
definitely did bring something up like
that on the record I appreciate you
saying that yeah because I feel like you
would be the guy to do it I'm the guy
that did it already Okay it's coming out
but I mean like I said we don't do
gratuitous violence we talk about what
it is in terms of what that exposes
right the fact that people were so
scared of him that they decided to shoot
other people that weren't even him the
fact that they were like okay you
actually have documented files and we
heard testimony from the city council
and so many racist things they said
Chris Dorner allegedly had documents and
recordings of high-level people in the
LAPD and government saying things that
were probably just as bad if not worse
so I think that there's a lot of sketch
that's around him there's other people
in that are in my proximity that I've
had a similar experience with that I'll
say okay I went to Penn State University
right and around the same time when the
sexual molestation allegations were
going on in Sandusky that other coaches
knew there was a district attorney who
was the district attorney in my case as
a matter of fact when I went to prison
um his name was Ray greekar and he was
investigating the Sandusky stuff and
guess what he was disappeared they found
his his he's still going he was he was
he was declared missing like and he's
declared dead you can look his name up
Ray Greek card
g-r-i-c-a-r and they found his laptop
missing a hard drive in a [ __ ] lake
or like in a river like a little stream
like a mile away from his house so this
guy who was investigating who could have
possibly covered up the rape allegations
gave whoever it was cover enough for
them to blame only the people who got
caught and none of the giant donors from
Penn State who part took another Circle
too yeah hey man I'm not going to stop
talking about this so if something
happens to me we all know what it is